-One, I'm so happy you're here
Two, I'm so happy "SNL" is bac
after a four-week break.
-Yeah.
-You had the holidays.
You went to London with
your husband, Conner,
A dear friend of ours
at the show. Used to work here
an incredibly funny guy.
Did you guys have fun in London?
-We had such a nice time.
Yeah, I mean, I'm from Arizona
So most of our vacations -
-Whoo!
-Oh, and hello.
But most of our vacations
was like,
"We're going to drive across
Utah."
[ Laughter ]
You know?
-Yeah.
-And so, yeah, we went --
Now we have TV money.
And we went to London.
[ Laughter ]
And it was so beautiful
and so nice.
-I mean, was it romantic?
Did you have moments of romanc
with Conner?
-You know, how can you not
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-But, yeah.
I mean, we had such a lovely -
We went on walks.
We sat by fireplaces.
We went on this walk in, like,
a beautiful garden.
There were swans everywhere,
and, like, beautiful birds
flying all around.
And I will say that,
like, at the end of the walk
I was like, "There's a bunch
of bird [ bleep ]
on your shoulder, bud."
[ Laughter ]
And he did have like
a big drizzle
of bird dump on his shoulder
-Yeah.
-And I was like, "Oh, okay
I definitely probably have
something in my purse that can
like, help us get this off."
And the only thing that I coul
find to scrape the bird poop
off of him was an old packet
of diarrhea medicine from me
[ Laughter ]
Kind of a beautiful
full-circle moment.
-Yeah.
-And really, like,
a romantic tale for our kids
But, yeah, I did have to tak
my old diarrhea medicine
and scrape the dump
off my husband.
-Just like -- Just like London
Everything you'd want.
-Yes, it's known
for being fancy.
[ Laughter ]
-You spent your summer,
second summer a row, in Portland
working on your fantastic show
"Shrill."
Have you enjoyed your time
in Portland?
-Oh, I really love it there.
-Yeah.
-It's so dang nice.
And, yeah,
I love shooting there.
It's just the damn best.
-And it's good people, right
Like, there's really good crew
out there
because of "Portlandia."
And --
-Yeah. Yeah, we share a crew
"Doc Now!"
-"Documentary Now!", yeah.
-And "Portlandia."
And "Shrill."
We all use the same damn crew.
It's so nice.
-Your --
There's an episode where you'r
introducing your boyfriend
to your family in this seaso
of "Shrill."
-Yeah.
-Conner, your husband,
does not play your boyfriend
But he's in the show.
-Yeah, he plays
sort of my enemy.
-Yeah, I'm very --
It's like role play.
-Rrrrrrr!
[ Laughter ]
This is all about how horn
I am.
And how much I get nasty.
-Yes.
"Even bird [bleep] cannot
tamp down my affections!"
-[ Panting ]
-You -- but in real life,
what was it like
when you introduced Conner
to your family?
-Yeah, it was -- it was --
It was perfect. Of course.
-Yeah.
-No, it was -- It was bad.
[ Laughter ]
Only in that at the time,
Conner had this car, which
for me, was very fancy.
-This is Chicago, yes.
-In Chicago, yeah.
And this car,
I think it cost under $300
-Right. Hard to get a car
for under $300.
-That's what you think.
[ Laughter ]
And so my mom came to town
And we were going to dinner.
And I was like, "Actually,
my boyfriend's going to
pick us up."
And the car didn't have
a muffler,
which means that it sounds lik
a rocket ship going to the moon.
Just a full, like,
aaaaarnh!
The whole way there.
And then the car also
didn't run when it rained.
-Okay.
-So, you know,
classic car stuff.
-This one's not a rainer.
-Yeah.
-"I'm going to get you
in this car for $299.
But you don't want to take i
out when it's wet."
-Also, it's like,
probably shouldn't be
riding in the vehicle
that can't be a little wet
-Yeah.
-But basically, then after
dinner, it started to rain
But we were already in the car
And so we were like, "We got
to just try and make it here."
But it started to rain so hard
that we couldn't see
out the windows.
And the windshield wipers
didn't work.
So I was in the front seat
And he was in the driver's seat.
And we both were holding
the windshield wipers
trying to just, like,
get to the end.
And my mom was in the back
And I was like,
"He's nice, right?"
[ Laughter ]
-You've been out doing a lot
of press, you were telling me,
the last two weeks promoting
"Shrill."
-Oh, yeah, yeah.
-Nice to have the time off
from "SNL."
You were back in Chicago.
-Yeah.
-And you were doing an event
-Yeah, it was kind of like
a live radio show.
So there were lots of kids
in the audience,
which was kind of fun.
-Yeah.
-And, you know, I definitely
realized, like,
"This is not my target
audience," at a certain point.
Because I was like, doing
my best to, like, keep it fun.
And I definitely, like,
zeroed in on, like,
a fat little boy
dead asleep on his mom.
-Yeah. Like, toddler?
-No, I -- I would put him at
like, a solid 11 years old
[ Laughter ]
And you got to imagine, like
an Augustus Gloop.
-Yeah, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-A nice little sack of circles
like, just absolutely
dead asleep,
you know?
-Uh-huh.
-And so that kind of put m
in my head,
But I was like, "Barrel through.
You've put this boy to sleep."
And -- and then,
I'm not kidding,
I looked over and there wa
a second fat little Chicago bo
dead asleep in the audience.
[ Laughter ]
And so now I got two Gloops kind
of sleeping through my stuff
And I hate to tell you this, but
there was a third little boy
-There was a third?
It does -- these things
do happen in threes, yes.
-And I was like,
"Am I, like, the pied pipe
who can put fat boys to sleep?
[ Laughter ]
Or what? I don't know.
But it shook me deeply.
So I need this pretty bad.
[ Laughter ]
-There you go.
[ Cheers and applause ]